hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play black
snow ok someone said that there was
something over here by the kennels and
holy crap it's already cold I'm already
dying I'm already dying
something said that there was like a
rebar by the door that was broke so let
me hurry over here
it was rebar by the door is that it I
think that might be it
Oh get it get it get it get it I used to
rebar yeah so thank you guy who said
that someone else oh my oh my oh that
dog is nailed to the wall holy crap now
man it does not look happy in here it's
also d saturated so I don't know where
all the color went hello ok so there's a
dead guy in there can I get in there
yeah can I get up oh I can I didn't
think that's gonna work
wow that actually did ok Oh aw crap I
just used him Oh Oh F oh mother oh oh oh
no oh no oh no this reminds me of
penumbra and the thing impaled by a
harpoon
who else on a harpoon in here there's
very not enough room for pudding in this
place I know you need to lead to good
you know six feet by six feet to get
some solid poon action going on master
and dog into the last month okay so I'm
taking this with me I'm not throwing it
in that room take it use it all good
golly uh-huh
oh don't tell me there are shadows in
here please please don't let there be
shot as anything but shadows haha buy
this game so much oh god dude dubis
mother of ah ah ha ha ha ha
play oh uh okay got one last Oh God let
me save saved one last one of these left
gimme okay take two hundred oh god oh
god oh god oh don't kill me don't kill
me all right
Baban Wow okay jump huh so you can't get
to what you can't see wow I'm so pro for
you
Wow ah right in the dark what am i dying
is there anything in here oh ah ah you
got a skylight ya betch [ __ ] up oh oh no
don't go out no
I'm alone in the darkness
was there nothing in here
oh I figure if there was a shadow in
here I'd be dead by now
oh so I freaked out for nothing eh well
I hope I scared off all the monsters
uh-huh
okay what's that hi wait I see you how
do I open that door ACK still dark oh I
sure wish I had you know a flare the aya
hang on let me let me reload and use
that flare and not panic I may have
overreacted just a wee little just a
little bit okay so now that I know I'm
not gonna die so why is this one locked
there Kia near those was a fine looking
on the shelves nothing
oh no oh come on you don't last at all
you're like a disappointing boyfriend
done it ah
not me of course no quick not me okay
there's got to be something up there
that I need I didn't see a way to get it
up well magic reload again try to find
my way you didn't see anything you
people didn't see anything nothing you
didn't a totally legitimate legitimate
all right there's got to be a way up
there I think I almost saw it when I was
trying to freaking out I saw a ha so
fight crouch jump up no I need to find
something - hi hi hi I need that I need
it I don't run out now you dick on you
son of a monkey [ __ ] alright so uh and
then it's gone oh and there is no
flashlight by the way I'm pressing f NZ
for those people that said there was and
who didn't know what they were talking
about obviously uh autofocus okay thank
you so easy nothing you doing nothing so
I've checked almost everywhere in that
room there's got to be like a box that I
can bring or maybe one of these bear can
I pick this up I can push it ah Boosh is
so good
ah bollocks can't pick you up him too
wimpy I'm too wimpy maybe I could do it
anyway come here we're gonna try this
haha oh god oh god
can't see pushing invisible barrel ah ah
ah what is this
what is this Emmett oh my god ahh bra
bra I'm gonna do it before I used all
the the flares so I don't just have one
how could I be silly okay so
okay now I save ha ha running there are
no shadows those are just weird noises
to scare me like that one Holly how all
that huh ok so how do i how do I get up
you anything ah
oh my so there is something you son of a
[ __ ]
you lied to me you lied maybe I lost it
in my jumping action
I musta I must have been too Pro I must
have been so pro and not even understood
how Pro I was ah I thought it was right
by me
I cut huh
ha-ah why did I reload my save uh-huh oh
no oh no I can't get back in one room
are you scared no baby oh baby my baby
okay bye
kill me don't kill me brah brah bring
brah what's this hole know off well I
got I got thrown all over the place
Oh God Dirk now Oh
Mel you betcha I like it here
I can't do anything cuz I'm too stupid I
can figure it out
haha oh maybe if I climb up on this
thing
ah what the hey wait what is this is the
snowcat we wrote in on go alright
am i up here haha [ __ ] yeah nailed it
ahaha now what's up here
wait whoa let's go whoa wait epic
knuckle scratch okay why am i why am up
I'm all sweaty though yeah okay um I
don't
okay I found a box just actually have
supplies in it I guess I'll never know
now maybe there's a way up on this vent
into that room maybe whoa ha ha ha ha ha
winner come poot or comp you take little
blue my hands right ignition key
navigational map biodiesel tire link ah
crap I need to find this stuff donor
boom boom boom okay how do I get out
again
OOP ah grows in multi black snow
infestation oh no known cure
dehumidifiers minimally effective only
delays onset victims not dead
what spore cloud still contains victims
consciousness absolutely is served an
improbable
what what what what I must be infected I
must be
must be how do I get out again and now
get high how'd it what was the button
that I used to control how's it okay
okay alright so let me just take this
and whatever this is I guess not open
not now and then Hello Baby how you
doing did you see how brave I was out
there I did now melted like Baus so
bounce like I'm so pro baby mmm oh yo
you ladies watching I know I know I know
you're probably huh how are you so
amazing I'm just like yeah it comes
naturally yeah that's it okay I can't
figure out how this ladder works I'm
that bad at games ah here we go
oh hello dead guys ah what dead Hey ha
ha ha oh it suddenly for anything what's
ugly breathing it's suddenly freezing ah
baloney baloney I'm dead I'm dead I'm so
dead what do I do
what do we do Vic no huh boss
ah can't figure ladder out for life of
me almost I almost died dead what the
hell was that oh yeah this game this
game is IR ha
paranoia how does it come time wears a
humidifier that someone said there was
one in here and they must have lied to
me Thule everybody else in my life oh
here we go
mom ah yes that is dot da sees much
better yah
ah finally okay so that's just one
glimmer of good news you turn on the
power down there maybe it did but I
don't have enough health to try that
where's the dingdong damn or is it a
humidifier is it a heater
no what where's it supposed to be ah
bodyslam what no bet I can't I have no
weapons to break you with all right
whatever I can melt the door here whoosh
ahh
and then I can go outside that didn't do
it ah there we go
oh um it's too cold I can't go outside
it's too cold I'm gonna die ha ha ha woo
fine can disturb I'll find a fine
treadley okay where's it ah someone lied
to me I do really think I want to do
that just gone Yin until lies yes okay I
can't I do not see any sort of heater in
here ergo I'm thinking I might be boned
oh hello baby okay I am boned bond is I
am bond I are oh I didn't even have that
much health to begin with so it's not
like I could go back to an old save
alright fine what okay okay alright
I'm gonna what am I gonna do what I
gotta do I'm gonna what am I gonna brave
the elements out here I mean fudgesicles
it's bloody it's bleed bloody cold out
here I don't have the help through deal
it above a frothing my dear oh yeah
maybe if I go back in here there's a
heater in here that I could take
advantage of I want to go in here I know
for a fact there are shadows in here
Rhode Island they scare you did I scare
you
I scared me okay come on how long in
this loading green tank the source and
reason is for Fisher ok wheel ahhh
gaaaahhhh ok epic leap ok this one was
done Oh yup they're still here damn it
this one done - I don't have anything
dongnam Heat I'm gonna die whoa hello I
saw that ah
after you alright so hey hey now I'm
thinking if I go down this hallway again
I could try to find another room with a
heater maybe nope ah if star visited I
just know she disturbing at hostile
ocean are you still there
[ __ ] I'm dead I'm nah ah I'm boned I'm
I'm boned I'm boned this Maximus is my
name hey hey no I liked it but I hate
this game
okay so uh yeah I think I managed to do
this whole game this whole video was
just scare myself I gotta get to the
counter real quick before I end this
episode before I freeze to death
yeah and then you guys can hold my hand
like little baby through this cuz I
can't help myself I am little scared
baby I'm little little scared EVP when
it comes to this game oh man I have the
time I'm just scared myself but man okay
so thank you all so much for watching
give me tips in the comments below and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
be scary
oh what's that one behind me haha
predicted it Oh called it I'm the blue I
know your tricks can't give me